it's a culture in New York City
basketball it's in every borough in
every community basketball hoops are a
big part about the youth of New York
City you can go to a park by yourself
with a basketball you don't need nobody
else you can go with two people you're
gonna go with four people and you know
you know it keeps the kids off the
street keeps them maybe out of trouble
and it might give them something to look
forward to John and his fellow
blacksmiths of the New York City Parks
Department make and repair everything
from lock boxes to lifeguard chairs but
some of their most iconic work is hand
making the basketball hoops in many of
the city's parks and playgrounds
this is the last out that that's
actually the rim that's five eight
inches in diameter fifty-eight 9/16 in
length put initial bend in the first
four inches then we put it in the roller
and roll
every one of these hoops are made like
the individual hoops you know none of
them are exactly the same I believe
there's a value in making them because
the quality is much better than what you
can buy we made one of these originally
back in I think 1994-95 over the years I
probably made over maybe a thousand rims
this is your final product New York City
Parks Department basketball room over
the course of a year John and the other
blacksmith's craft and replace up to a
hundred rims throughout the city's
courts they're made by city workers and
they're being played by city kids what's
more New Yawk the net
I watched college basketball and you
always hear all these colleges around
the country this kid is from Brooklyn
this kid is from the Bronx so probably
in their playing days someplace along
the way they all played on New York City
rims and it probably was a help in the
process of the making but they were